hey guys if you haven't seen the
hoverboards that we've been cruising
around on it's basically my favorite
thing ever and there was an amazing
video that these guys did it was a
synchronized to music video to Justin
Bieber's what do you mean well you're
gonna learn I hit the sea walk real
quick so a big shout out I'm hoping he
doesn't get upset with me for using his
song because I found an instrumental
version of the Justin Bieber song by jet
official go check it out I'll put a link
of description honestly it's so freakin
good I think I've got my dancers ready
you do we're gonna use his instrumental
and honestly like bro I'm subscribing
well Jenn official is his channel and
I'm gonna beat are you seeing this oh
the stomach ride it did it the way to
treat a friend
oh boy yeah it's so good see that is a
lot don't trip I can't control this oh
don't bug me I'm up for it
she got on this side I cheat on your
side yeah wicked this way yeah oh this
might be bad you're doing it this is
pretty cool actually
oh come on wait wait you know wait all
right okay you go for I'll go back I go
forward yeah I look forward yeah we Ford
I got [__] oh god okay okay okay wait
why would we Bolton sorry I can't really
okay sure what I'm doing right now okay
oh wait okay wait Obama oh wait okay
Jen we need help there's not really much
hold on but wait one might not move it
though I know you're looking yourself
good okay wait oh oh the transition nice
what can I come back - oh okay
there is something on the ground all
right so how do we get
oh cool
this is what you're doing if you had it
on other ones gone all right Linda this
one over here I can't do it I don't have
the core strength you got a real mommy
money
high five oh no I got it
like I'm ready I think that to riding
that that to to passenger my roller ride
was pretty slick to every slick look
it's a whole long oh you're there
oh you're there look at that money now
I'll take your hand off
you just crunch your abs there you go
that was good what do you mean all right
all right guys thanks for watching I'm
not really sure what you watched but I
think that we should still try to do one
day separate the signal is get do that
one passenger here you go I think you
need to do is have a follow-up of the
three small ones have map Rica's I great
wait what we need to have Suzie and one
low because she's actually to be inside
with her this is great oh my gosh
stay tuned fun is coming up I love you
guys wow so sixteen minutes of BS cool
the last one was like perfect continuing
on with these little guys you want to
just make a nice little round circle
somewhere to kind of make it look like a
broken little eggie